e
okay get going here
um president of Howard would you like to
pledge to the of United States of
America the for stands
Nation
all okay welcome I apologize for being a
little late um you'll understand in a
minute um going to open up the notice a
uh public hearing for the house election
law committee on Senate Bill 489 FN
relative to election audits uh I believe
Senator gray is here to introduce the
bill Senator welcome uh thank you Mr
chair my name is James Gray I am the
senator representing Senate District 6
which starts up in Alton gton comes down
Route 11 to Rochester and the
communities in between uh this bill is a
continuation of uh the audits that we
preliminarily uh authorized a couple
years ago uh tried them for a year they
worked out very well uh it's got some
updates with Lessons Learned in there uh
and uh again uh we're trying to provide
uh the people with assurance that the
elections are conducted properly and
that uh the results that they get are
uh uh with the new machines now
the uh ability to um do certain things
is enhanced with those uh one of the
things that I will point out that's
different than what we've done in the
past is on page two and it goes into
lines 22 21
through um 25 I guess and that's uh
allowing uh certain ballots to have a an
Auditor's Mark put on them uh so so that
uh if we take random ballots and uh
select a few you know that we are going
to do for our sample uh that those can
be uh identified during the scan process
so that we know how those ballots were
actually counted uh in the machine uh
and that was a request done in
conjunction with the Secretary of
State's office and I'd be happy to
answer any questions that you
have questions from the
committee F yes resent HR thank you um
how do you how would you go about
opening up the boxes and getting 50
ballots out can you explain that please
well the
process uh if you watched what we did
last time we did the whole thing um you
know opening the the boxes was part of
the audit procedure um and at that time
we scanned every ballot into there I
can't remember exactly whether we're
scanning each one of the ones now I
believe that we are uh but uh
again the way that it was done is that
they were done in groups of some
reasonable number okay and then inside
the machine it tallied the things that
were in those groups uh certainly uh one
of the ways to do this uh would have
been to say well I'm going to pick one
of those particular groups of ballots
because you can get the reports and they
thought it was better to be able to put
a mark on the ballot an auditor Mark in
a field you know somewhere not
associated with any of the election
results and then be able to pull that
back from from the uh the machine uh so
that it wasn't you know this group that
group and this other group but it was
more random thing so uh you know they're
open you know they're processed uh the
resealed further questions
representative
we and thank you Mr chair and thank you
Senator gray for taking my question um
is there any what's the rationale for
the 2% sampling size uh we had to pick a
number uh and if you go into statistics
uh trying to figure out what the
standard deviations are what you know
the positives are you know that's uh if
you you take within five standard
deviation or with within a standard
deviation but you you narrow it you get
to a
99.86 whatever percent accuracy you know
the mathematicians all know that kind of
stuff um but the numbers in here more
rely on what we think is reasonable what
do we think we could do uh with the
average machine in New Hampshire around
2,000 to 3,000 ballots go through it on
Election Day you know that certainly
also injured into our calculations and
trying to do uh a a count in the morning
and a count in the afternoon for the two
days uh for each machine that we deploy
uh so that would be uh you know two
deploying two machines so we would have
eight in total which is the number that
you see there again we're we're trying
to keep the numbers reasonable but also
have that assurance and I think although
some people would like to see that
number smaller some people would like to
see it bigger I think we we've got as
best to compromise as that I could come
up with okay thank
you further questions from the
committee oh I'm sorry representative
Lane thank you thank you Senator gray
for taking my question um I actually
have two so um um on where it talks
about the paper ballots for each device
audited shall be processed by the audit
equipment what is the audit equipment I
guess I just wasn't in the in the last
bill that we had that again sunsetted
after the first
application uh the Secretary of State
went out and did a procurement of
scanning equipment that could be used to
count the votes on the ballot um and
that along with the the uh the the
computer that goes along with the
scanning equipment and the printers and
all of that that constitutes the audit
equipment so it's the same as best I
know it's the same equipment that we
used two years ago when we did the last
ones okay um take a followup it's not
actually it's a followup it's just a sec
a different question sure
um
what are there any Criterion for the
selection of the audit locations or is
this something that the secretary would
just pick have the vision of a fishbowl
with all the numbers but how how does
how does that happen when they when if
you're I'm going to change your question
just slightly and say when we pick the
devices that we're going to audit
because we're not auditing locations
we're auditing devices and as long as
the ballots are seg at and that's one of
the reasons to give the the the
community notice if they've got multiple
machines so that we don't have to scan
all the ballots through all the machines
we only have to segregate the ballots
that went through one particular machine
uh but uh what we've done is is in here
we talk about that they are able to
group these into various groups of so if
we want to make sure that we we scan
voting Works ones and we scan the ones
from Dominion okay and you know on about
an equal basis or we want to take a
large community and we also want to take
a medium-sized Community or a small
community they are able to segregate
those into those and then that choice
from that community that they establish
will be a random draw or you know
somebody throwing a dart however they
it
um thank you I just wasn't quite sure
how that happened and then um is it the
Secretary of State alone or is it his
staff I mean how does that work I think
that the secretary of state is
represented uh and I I I think that uh
uh I did not enter into how that
selection was done uh they assured me
that it was done in a random basis and
from the results that I saw on the last
time uh we had different parts of the
state we had different size communities
we had all of those things would make me
believe that they did a very good job of
that representative bernon thank you um
I have a question on line 14 of page one
um it says the devices and the towns or
city wards where devices to be audited
are located shall be
nonpublic and then in the following
section it says
um that the secretary shall not announce
until after the polls are open on
Election Day and so I'm wondering if
um if the secretary is announcing
it on Election Day would that not be
public and are those two lines in
conflict with each other uh certainly
the information is going to be public at
some point uh the point that we're
trying to get to here is that if the
general public knew what machines we
were going to be auditing on what day uh
that that would defeat the purpose of
doing the audit in the first place
because you would not do anything so we
want before we we identify which
machines and which communities those
machines are in we want to make sure
that they are up and running on Election
Day and that no other modifications
would be made to them after they're put
into the service and so I don't see the
inconsistency in there this is that
their selection criteria would not be
done in an open session you know when
they pick the machines uh they would not
be announced ahead of time uh the
assignment of the people who actually go
out to the polls U because what they've
done in the past is they've actually
hadn't you know sent somebody to those
locations to help them and make sure
that they were able to segregate the
balance that went through that
particular machine all of those things
need to be nonpublic so that these uh
you know that the the the randomness of
the count and not allowing any
modifications can all happen uh before
we actually go and uh announce the
machine but but we want to announce them
earlier in the day than what we did
before because in in a large election or
a place a community that that is trying
to get away with one machine where they
might better have more machines uh that
if they start putting ballots into a box
because the machine is you know full uh
the bin is full uh then you lose the
opportunity to segregate the balance for
that particular machine and it makes
that audit process much more
difficult representative rafter thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question um you so you have done some of
these audits on kind of a trial basis
I'm just curious how many times you
found discrepancies between the original
voting machines and the audit equipment
uh those reports are all available
online
you because the different
scanners and I'll I'll back up just a
little bit and move the mic so I can see
you uh the scanners certainly the
sensitivity and selectivity of how they
interpret those ovals are going to be
slightly different okay and so we do not
expect that the count be exact okay
because of that because of the limited
technology that we have we don't know uh
when we did the Windom audit uh there
was some machines that uh uh the lights
were very sensitive some machines the
lights weren't as sensitive in the
window machine but overall we we got a
very good count and the reason that we
actually announced those results prior
to the last day to request a recount is
so that
the people the candidates who are being
voted for can look at those results and
say yeah there there's enough of a
difference between this machine that
machine uh that I do want to recount uh
it also allows the Secretary of State to
review those results and say we need to
do more of an audit which is also in in
the bill you know that allows them to do
that so slight difference yeah we expect
that there will be you know one two
depending upon but you know that may be
one or two per 500 or a thousand uh and
not a large number but again you know
giving you if your uh race was being uh
audited okay the opportunity to say yeah
there is a difference here and I want
that recount you have the opportunity to
do
it further questions from the
committee I just want to clarify so this
is the basically reinstalling the audit
that Sunset and then adding a provision
for uh to
65936 rent it it in a nutshell in a
nutshell uh and it also updates the
language so that you know uh any
differences between the acote machines
and the new the authorized machines you
know will be taken into
consideration okay any other questions
from the committee I'm seeing none thank
you thank you gray um Senator you're not
introducing the next bill right no um
okay uh next up will be Olivia zinc with
open de actually excuse me let's go to
Aaron Hennessy I apologize dep secretary
sorry I love you I she was deputy
entry good morning everyone Aaron
Hennessy deputy secretary of state I
just want to say uh we support this
legislation um I do want to point out uh
representative Brennan's question about
the um non-public maybe there could be a
few words added in that section just to
make it clear that at some point we do
have to announce Which towns we're
auditing um in the past our audits have
been um very successful and proven that
the devices that we use here in New
Hampshire to count our ballots um are
very um efficient and um um accurate uh
we would love to see these come back
into legislation so that in September
and November and in future presidential
primaries we can continue to um have
audits for um for transparency purposes
to assure that everyone here in New
Hampshire that um the machines that we
use to tabulate our results are accurate
um just a reminder we have um two
different ballot counting devices in use
here now in New Hampshire the ACU vote
and the voting Works device the voting
Works device was used in five different
locations in March town meeting um we
anticipate that in some point in the
future we'll have a third the Dominion
device um we do not use any of these
brands for the um the tab ation or the
odd purposes we use a clear ballot
device to audit um the ballots that come
that are tabulated by any of those two
or possibly three machines uh we think
that's a good way to um improve
transparency um and that device um is
constantly tested to make sure that it
can accurately count the ballots that
are being programmed by the two to
possibly three different vendors we have
so uh to sum it up I am um very
supportive of this legislation our
office is I'm happy today questions if
you have
committee okay thank you that was okay
uh next up now we have Miss syc I
fake uh good morning members of the
committee uh for the record I'm a voter
Olivia zinc voter in Franklin and
executive director of open democracy and
we are in support of post-election
audits um post-election audits are
simple um and a proven way to increase
confidence um I just want to sort of
answer representative rafter question um
in 2022 we had four post-election audits
there's a 72 76 page report on the
Secretary of State's website um but in
Tilton um there was um
1,546 ballots that were run through the
Acura vote machine on ction day and the
clear B ballot audit had the identical
amount um they also audited Durham and
5,873 and the audit showed that there
were
5,872 so there was one ballot different
and they show the documentation on that
summersworth ward 3 was another
community in 2022 that was audited on
Election Day ACU vote showed
856 ballots and clear ballot um showed
8,5 um 104 so two ballots different on
Election uh from the post- elction
Audits and then they also did Pembrook
um and it was
3,241 and then on the clear ballot
showed um
3,248 so there was seven ballots
different and that could just be things
that were you know put on the side
pocket on Election Day or there could
there's reasons in the in the report
shows the different discrepancies and
also people don't read the instructions
on the top of the ballot on how to Mark
a ballot so it says fill in the oval and
people do all Kind Checks X's all kinds
of crazy things that um are showing
those um differences but I also would
want to mention um post elction audits
happen across the country 34 other
community 30 or four other states have
um these things we passed a trial
version um that happened
after the 2022 elections you passed
another bill to to to make this happen
and it lost in Committee of conference
and I think that you know eight eight
ballot counting devices was what the
Senate has in this bill and I think the
house might have took a six ballot
counting devices position there was like
a difference between which ones um but I
however many you do six or eight I think
it's important that you do it or four
like you did um two years ago so I think
that's the important thing and I think
the other thing I'll just mention is
that maybe in line 15 you can say prior
to election day so prior to election day
the it's non-public which machines
you're going to do and then that sort of
solves your um problem with it being
announced on Election Day and becomes
public that's just one suggestion in
line 15 on on page
one um I'm happy to take any
questions yes representative warar um uh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um so the numbers you just
read off from the report are
substantially more substantially more
than the amounts listed here for the
sampling I'm sorry that I didn't direct
this question to deputy secretary
earlier but um no my understanding is
that they do the ballots that were run
through the machine and then they they
look at paper ballots they look at 50
paper ballots so they do the scan part
and then they look at 50 paper ballots
or 2% so you're you're hand you're doing
hand count 2% hand count it's yeah you
the the paper ballot is a sort of person
looking at that many ballots and the
Machine runs through everything that the
machine looked at but then they just
randomly select 50 ballots where real
humans look at them so that's just the
and I think that you know um some of the
folks that do this nationally say it
should be a 100 ballots but whatever I
think it's important that you look at
some thank you for clarifying that I now
so I see on line two of page two the
physical
examination of it and so
it's it it's sort a uh pseudo hand
counter hand you know ver manual
verification of the process he selected
so thank you for that clarification yeah
and I and I think on the other point is
like some communities have multiple
machines in their town so if you pick
Dairy they have multiple machines or
Bedford has multiple machines they're
just doing the ballots that were run
through one machine um if you picked
Franklin Ward 2 we only use one machine
so it's easy to sort of say that one
machine in Franklin War I is the one
machine but in some of the other ones
you wouldn't know which of the multiple
machines they're using so I think that's
where you have to have that announcement
to election workers on Election Day so
that they know everything that runs
through this machine has to be boxed up
separately to go to the Post elction
audit because it could get really
confusing
if I mean you want it to be
clean further questions from the
committee saying thenone thank you Miss
langel good morning
um for the record my name is Katherine
LEL I'm a 20-year-old voter from conquer
and I'm a student at St Ansel College um
I'm going to say this I'm a psych major
so I look a lot at statistics and I was
looking through this bill and there's a
lot of really good things in here um
when we're talking about like
operational definitions um statistics
processes Etc so I'll say that but I'll
also echo my Superior in saying that um
postelection audits are an important
step um in maintaining Integrity of New
Hampshire elections um in the face of a
potentially tumultuous election season
um addressing concerns of those faced
with mistrust in our elections and this
can assure voters of our safe and secure
system um this legislation adds another
layer of accuracy and certainty in the
reporting of results and um trans that
transparency that was discussed so in
the favor of bra I'm G to stop there if
anyone has any questions I'm happy to
take a crack at them other questions
from the committee
uh here seeing none thank you thank you
um that's all of the pink cards that I
have in my possession represent anenberg
can you grab
me
oops thank you and it is blank um so no
one no one was
it all right well I'll count I'll read
the online count a minute we'll get
going on the next thing um going to
close the public hearing on S sp49 open
the public hearing on S sp535
representative Perkins COA thank you
welcome to uh election law for the
purpose of introduction I'm sorry let me
read the bill title I apologize um we're
going to start the public hearing on
Senate Bill 535 relative to absentee
ballot forms now you're recognize
Senator perk SK I apologize good morning
representative Barry um or shall I say
chair and members of the election law
committee it's nice to be here I see
several familiar faces um for the record
I am Senator Rebecca Perkins quoka from
Senate District 21 the city of
Portsmouth and the towns of Durham Lee
Madbury Newcastle newfields Newington
and New Market I have all the news um
today I am introducing Senate Bill 535
an act relative to absentee ballot forms
this bill amends RSA
6574 to align it with RSA
6571 the purpose of the bill is not to
change policy or to expand the
requirements regarding absentee voting
in any way it is simply correcting two
misaligned conflicting State statutes SP
535 updates the ction of the absentee
ballot request form regarding receiving
an absentee ballot in the case of a
winter storm warning due to concerns
about traveling to the polls in doing so
it corrects the conflicting language
that regulates who
qualifies the change will
um this change will directly affect that
the ballot request form to match RSA
6571 regarding the scenario will match
up I'm happy to take any questions other
questions from the committee
um I imagine not because we have already
passed this um so okay not this bill but
we passed this um I believe it is I
think we voted it out last week right
yeah we voted it out last week so I
think you guys have ours which is
actually even more simplistic than this
okay um does the same thing okay um so
good luck great good luck uh would you
like the bill number Senator I HB 1119
uh h HP 1119 HB 1119 I will be on the
lookout great it was actually our own
prud home O'Brien represent PR obb
brien's Bill and literally same thing so
okay okay wonderful all right any other
um uh questions or I didn't really even
have a question um all right seeing none
thank you um thank you very much do have
one pink card rep uh representative zc
democracy good morning again for the
record Olivia Franklin New Hampshire
executive director of open democracy um
I just want to say that absentee ballot
uh absentee voting is nonpartisan
according to the institute for uh
responsive government re research shows
that no party gains anything from having
allowing absentee loss uh we were very
lucky this year with Town meetings that
we didn't have snowstorms last week um
and no one needed to cancel elections
but in the case that uh winter storms uh
blizzards happen on Election Day this um
uh strikes the language on page one line
uh 24 um that I'm infirmed um I'm
elderly affirmed or have a physical
disability um and I think that it's
important that anyone who's concerned
about a winter storm can vote even if
they're not elderly or infirmed um and I
want to thank this committee and Kathy
Pruno O'Brien H who has a slightly
different version of this bill that does
that strikes slightely different
language but the concept is very very
much the same I did bring a copy of the
absentee ballot request form so you can
see the language of uh elderly infirmed
on the prior to election day but
basically it makes this form the same as
the
statute okay questions from the
committee saying none thank you I have
no other pink cards um online I was
ready to go online this time there were
12 people in support four opposed uh on
48 n since I wasn't quick on the draw on
that one uh there was 14 in support zero
opposed uh there was here there was one
person signed up in support who did not
speak that happens to be the Secretary
of State's office um with that I will
close the public hearing on SB
535 um
and wow look at that timing it is
10:31 right just some say some say best
scheduling ever
um okay so um why don't we we'll open up
the executive session for the house
election law committee um we're going to
start with House Bill 1091 relative to
financing of political
committees
um excuse me let me pull up my notes
here before we make a motion it's okay
that's the worst thing that happens to
me it'll be a good day okay here we go
all right so
um I will make a um ought to pass motion
on House Bill 1091 I believe
representative Lane would you like to
Second
it I'm happy to second I am sure um
representative Lane are there any
amendments to House Bill
1091 uh yes there is amendment that
should be in front of you that we got
about 9:30 this morning uh 2024 d11
93h okay representative Lane uh moves
Amendment
2024-the Lane would you like to speak to
your motion um um yes I've been going
through it to make sure because of our
deadline to make sure that um OS and and
they've been wonderful they've been very
helpful working with me on this um so
that they caught all the changes and I I
have a few little knits that we need
need to make um ones a date but I I want
to just um for people who brought up
suggestions if you want to look to see
if your suggestion is in here um and
what you wanted um I I'll try to
remember where it is and I can point you
to it um and then um I I will say that
representative Howard's language is from
his bill is not in here and we added in
the um language for the waiver U so if
someone uh wants a waiver from a
reporting um uh
requirement it
me
sorry
I hope it made it in
here okay in case anybody's wondering
why we're doing this one first it's
because we're going to go through the
amendment and if we find things that are
wrong we will hopefully have time with
OS to fix the amendment and take it up
at the end of Executives that's why
we're starting with this one so please
do your due diligence
um and and take a good long look we have
time um but we do have to act on this
bill
be I guess I would ask um representative
it I'm looking for the the waiver term
where the reports that we were going to
let people who could apply for a waver
to the secretary of state from um filing
online I think our committee researcher
out and and what
much
30 okay so basically if you spend less
than
3,000 and um you don't possess a
computer the skills to file statements
pursuant um you ask for a waiver and um
and the secretary of state will look at
it and um approve or disapprove uh we
can tweak this later in after a couple
years as people will get used to the
system um my guess is uh and and the
secretary deputy secretary of state just
told me that everybody is entered into
the online campaign system because if we
don't do it they do it so that even if
you haven't um registered as a candidate
you're required to register but they
will register you at least you're in the
system so that's that one um I I would
like to
um let people know that we our version
of the this version of the bill is
phasing in using the online system
and so the first time somebody will be
required to use the online system would
be for the
next we're facing it in we're having the
governor the executive counsel and the
state
senate go first because there's less of
them and we thought it might be easier
to get some of the quirks out before we
uh put 400 of us into the system and
start using it and uh asking a lot of
questions so the thought is um that the
way we defined election cycle it starts
21 days after the election so the
election cycle for
2026 starts 21 days
after election in
date 26 for 26 the election cycle starts
that day 21 days after and goes
through next 21 days after the 26
election and the reason we did that was
because people you know came pay a lot
and raise money a lot and we want them
to be able you know to capture those and
require them to um be transparent about
it we're not limiting them it's just to
be transparent about it so it it that's
on the bottom of page four it's line
37 so I just want to flag that because
originally when we had defined U we had
not defined election cycle and it was a
different date it was uh in in
2025 and then if you go over on page
five uh line three that date is wrong it
should be November 24th
2025 this is
why I just wanted everybody to look at
it because it just because this is a an
important date so it would be yeah two
years later right yeah
okay so we do we need to fix that yeah
I'm going to have her fix that um and
there was a a couple other they're under
um because we're taking out the
definition of political advocacy
committee um it popped up in the um
chart where you where they have uh how
how much an individual can donate and
that
chart
page six yeah so that will take that out
and that's one other little knit so
anything like grammar and misspellings
they can we can fix if we when we get
over to the Senate side um and uh also
when it's enrolled they will usually fix
those kind of things um
so that's it
I guess I would like to go through it
one one time more before we vote so can
I
go back in the
corner because it's 13 pages long and we
yeah everybody we're in we're in no rush
on this um does anybody
see anything else that we need to flag
on
this okay um and I thank everybody's
patience and actually trust yeah because
this is been a big it's it's been a it's
been a long list it's it's been a long
it's been a long way and it's it's uh I
you did L you did get the language from
the senate about the font size and the
clarity of report that is just to
clarify that is in this that is in this
amendment yeah it's in here um so when
we go to vote on that
later that language is in this
amendment um and right now because of
we're going to we're mandating the
online after a certain time that will
gradually disappear because that allows
for PDFs and that kind of stuff so if
you're entering it directly into the
online system the that piece won't be
here
yes the font size yes the infamous font
higher I can tell you where that road
ends if you'd like oh I've been
there yeah there's definitely not a pot
of gold any know that rainbow
um okay so we'll let representative Lane
go off and do that thing I will recess
house B 1091 we are taking this up today
so
don't don't go anywhere um I'll try to
sit over there and just go Page by Page
through it okay um and then I can come
back over yes representative anenberg uh
can you tell me where it shows or
reflects the font size uh let's take a
look
37 eight point
font there you
go one one other thing is we need to
make the we were going to make the
effective date of this section this
section only um immediately like 60 days
after passage and that way that stuff
all for this election will go in like
that then the rest of the bill will be
effective on January 1 2025 so I need to
clarify that at the last um on the last
page the goal is to incorporate the
language of s SP 530
into our larger campaign Finance reform
um so so yeah because there's that Bill
was 60 days after passage so I wanted
that section the same way so it it it's
kind of our first
step so we we are overhauling campaign
Finance while also updating campaign
finance and also changing campaign
Finance so what could go wrong
um so we we may be cleaning up some
unintended consequences next year yeah I
imagine we will um and that's okay um
but we're going to make
it I guess we we not we're we're in
recess we'll come back to discussion of
the bill but um okay um I'm going to
open up the executive session on Senate
Bill 490 FN and before you go
representative Lane I need
you uh to make the motion on
this uh 490 FN relative to the
checklist
e
it's okay I'll make the motion um okay
uh I'm going to move uh Senate Bill 490
FN uh to be inexpedient to legislate is
there a second representative weel
second me um speak to the motion real
quick um we've already pass this we
already passed a version of this out of
the house um I see no reason to take two
house positions the house already has a
position um it's up to the Senate what
they want to do with that um so I will
be uh while I appreciate the sentiment
of this bill I have already voted for
what I believe is a better version of
this bill um so I'm going to get rid of
this bill further discussion on the
motion of ined to legislate yes
representative War I'll just add uh per
my testimony on this bill the other day
is that I I really think that the
fiveyear cycle adds to a inconsist y
across elections I I think there was
ample evidence if if anyone reviewed the
email I sent to the committee or or read
the testimony that I presented in hard
copy on uh earlier so I think based on
that I I I don't think that this is a a
good thing to to set up for uh having
the elections to be inconsistent year-to
year and across uh different
presidential election election cycle so
um that's why I support the
itl further discussion on the motion of
any speaking to legislate on Senate Bill
490 hearing none the clerk will call the
role uh representative
quy
yes representative Alexander
yes representative pom O Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative bernham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative lean yes representative
Ward yes representative uh HR yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes with that
the motion any expedience to legislate
carries on a vote of 20 to Zer um any
objection to this bill being placed on
the consent calendar hearing none this
bill will be placed on the consent
calendar representative Lane can you
please have someone from your caucus
report okay thank you okay with that I
will close the public sorry the
executive session on Senate Bill
490 um I will open up the execu ative
session on Senate bill
530 um and um I will recognize myself to
make a motion of any expedient to
second please representative wey seconds
me thank you for leaving me that awkward
pause
um as I said during the recess executive
session on House Bill 1091 we are
incorporating this um bill into house
bill 1091 so there's no point in putting
two pieces forward um so I'm that that's
why I'm moving this the language was
taken verbatim and put in um almost
verbatim and put in um except we got to
amend to 91 for the correct um enactment
date so with that is there any other
530 hearing none Madam clerk Cloud the r
uh representative qua yes
representative Alexander yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes representive
G yes representative Howard yes
representative rafter yes and chairman
Barry chair votes yes without the motion
of any speed to legislate Caron vot of
2020 is there any objection to this bill
being placed on a consent calendar
hearing none this bill will be placed on
consent calendar um I will take care of
notes okay with that I'll close the
executive session for Senate Bill 5:30
we'll open up the executive s for Senate
Bill
um and I will recognize representative
motion thank you Mr chairman I move that
the committee find uh this bill
inexpedient to legislate I'll second
that motion um like to speak to your
motion representative
qua y uh yes thank you Mr chairman this
bill uh is very very similar to HB 11 19
which we passed out of this committee
recently uh like uh HP 1119 this bill
brings the uh contents of the absente
ballot request
form uh into consistency with the
underlying statute that defines the
eligibility
requirements for uh receiving an
absentee ballot therefore it's uh
thoroughly redundant and there's no need
to pass it therefore I am recommending
itl on it thank you y uh any other
further discussion on the motion of
expedient to legislate and I will Echo
that sentiment from the vice chairman of
we've already passed this they have the
Senate has it in their possession it's
cleared the house floor um so there's no
point in sending duplicative language
over to just add the confusion um any
other further discussion hearing none
Madam clerk call the role representative
quae yes repres representative Alexander
yes representative pom O'Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer representative Bay yes
representative Brennan representative
Grill yes representative Howard
representative Rapter yes uh chairman
Barry chair votes yes without the motion
Ving spe to legisl carizona vote of 20
to Z is there any objection this bill
being placed on the consent calendar
hearing none this bill will be placed on
the consent calendar I'll take care of
the report those are super easy because
we've already passed them so it's super
it's like two line report
um okay uh with that I will close the
executive session on Senate Bill
um
what I'm going to do is I'm going to I'm
going to recess for five minutes for so
the various cuses can meet for 489 um
because I know that there was um been
speaking with the ranking member
previously I know that the caucuses
wanted to discuss this so um you you
want 10 minutes representive Lane would
that be easier for you yeah okay so we
will meet back at 10
11:02 um representative Lane if your
caucus wants to stay in this room or use
that office that's fine I'll take my
what
e
okay uh are we all we're all back yep
okay um so so we are on if I haven't
opened it I'll I'll open it Senate Bill
uh 489 FN relative to election audits um
let me pull out my notes I don't know
why I'm talking without my notes um
motion can you turn your mic on uh thank
you Mr chair I'd like to move that 489
is on to pass okay is there a second
representative Woods seconds is there
any discussion on the motion of ought to
pass okay that's easy uh hearing none
the clerk will call the role on the
motion of V to pass on Senate Bill 49 uh
representative qu
yes uh representative Alex yes
representa Brian yes representative
inberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Herby Bia yes
representative Lane I just want to make
sure this is SB 489 correct okay
yes
yes yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rapor yes
chairman
Barry chair votes yes with that the
motion of oop pass carries on a vote of
20 to Z
um there it has a fiscal note so it
can't go on to the consent calendar um
so we will see it on the house
floor with that I will close the
489 uh let's get this one out of the way
uh going to open up the executive
session on Senate Bill
380 um relative to moving the state
primary date uh I will move this as
ought to pass
believe representative Osborne is
seconding me yep always nice when that
happens um is there discussion on the
380 yes representative Brennan thank you
Mr
chair um I am concerned about moving the
state primary to June it really disrupts
um the down ballot race es including
State Rep races it disrupts um our
election
season if the primary is moved to June
you have nonstop yearlong election
season you will have towns that have
town meeting in
March those candidates that file for
municipal offices file in January they
campaign through
February and then
March elections um town meeting
elections some towns hold their town
meeting in
April and some in May so you will be
having some some communities that are
dealing with elections from
January through
May and then they'll have a state
Primary in June State primary uh
candidates would be filing in about
March so you would have campaigning
between March and
June the winners of the state Primary in
June would then campaign from June to
November at what point do communities
get a break from campaigning from
political ads from mailers from yard
signs this would have a huge realworld
impact on our
constituents um I understand that
supporters of a junor
primary believe this is better for our
topof the ticket candidates our
Governors our um executive counsel I
understand that there is a quick
turnaround between our current state
Primary in September and our general
election in
November that's what it is um I
understand that it would be better for
those candidates but what about our
citizen legislature that we are so proud
of here in New Hampshire where we have
regular folks serving in our state
legislature making decisions for our
neighbors and our community does this
not make it more difficult for them to
run and serve in the state legislature
when in the second year of the bium they
would be still in the middle of
legislative work when they would be
expected to sign up to run and run a
campaign
um that's a lot for $100 a year and it's
not about money it's about
time regular folks serving in this state
legislature who work full-time will now
be expected to take time off for their
legislative work and campaigning if they
want to
win and I think a lot of us here
um we're certainly not here for the
money we're here because there's a
purpose in serving our
communities but we still
need um an
income right so this is disruptive to
candidates it's disruptive to our
communities who would be dealing with
this non-stop campaign year we'd be
lucky if we had no if we had December
off from campaign that's what a June
primary would do to us maybe we get
December off from campaign
this would also lead to a huge influx of
money into our elections if you are
concerned at all about money in our
elections the amount that is spent on
each election the amount of instate but
also outof State funds that flood into
our state for any
campaign you wouldn't support a June
primary so I'm asking all of you to
please consider the real world impact of
mov moving our state primary to June
where it will affect our constituents if
you are not here to serve your
constituents and and you are here to
make political power plays then by all
means support a June primary but if
you're here to serve your constituents
please consider the real world impact of
moving the state primary to June and
please vote no on the ought to pass
motion so another motion can be made
thank you there a further discussion on
the the
motion uh yes representative PM O'Brien
thank you Mr chairman something that
didn't come up uh in this conversation
but was always in the back of my mind
was hurricanes we recently had a
blizzard in my community and that was
very disruptive to the the um election
that we had last
year it's difficult to decide what to do
during a her a a blizzard but when
there's a hurricane this is high
September is Peak hurricane season I
feel like it's just a matter of time
when you deal with the same exact thing
so this is not a political power play
you could say this was out of concern
for my community with that that
you um any further discussion on the
motion I ought to pass um okay I will
end this discussion with my diet trive
and then we will call the vote um
pres Bren I I wrote down points to
things you read um non-stop campaigning
uh Chuck Morris Kelly aot sending
warmington Joyce Craig have been running
for governor now for approaching a year
so this notion that non-stop campaigning
is going to be a thing uh welcome to
2024 it's a thing it's already happening
um number two this solves our uocava
problem number three I have voted for
August in the past I have voted for June
in the past August meets defeat I want
to see this moved in the context of yava
so June is the option um as for
legislative work there's a lot of ways
to address that problem uh the first of
which is uh stop filing so many bills um
there's like a thousand plus for that
overwhelmingly go itl and on a consent
calendar that we have to have hearings
for and stuff like that so please like
we could fix that with rules um by the
way the house used to not meet in the
second year so if you want to if you
want to get together about working
people and young people being in the
legislature I'm happy to do that
stop filing so many bills have the
committee sessions meet later at night
so young people can actually join them
and make the committee make the
committee recommendation actually
binding um and then they will be
important uh make the committee smaller
would be another option to have more
working to have more working people
because now not everybody has to be on a
committee there's so many options to fix
our problem but at the end of the day
that's our problem um June September
doesn't happen to work well for me with
my what I do for work so what about me
um no we don't think like that um number
uh next one up is uh incumbents or the
primary is going to be the primary is
going to affect us and we're
incumbents incumbents are rarely primar
um and it is almost never successful so
in 2022 I think that there were three
out of the 400 members were successfully
primaried out so less than 1% so 99% uh
are totally fine um not really worried
about that huge Flux Of Money uh it's an
argument of fallacy um the current
program suggests that only the money
only follows the incumbent who doesn't
have a primary so it's not on an even
footing um the it's time to put these on
an even footing and for the last one
here to serve a
constituents I agree this would more
impact the upper ticket than the down
ticket I'll agree with that um 47% of
New Hampshire Republicans have been
represented 5% of the time in
Congressional races over the last 10
years one of the biggest reasons why is
because we have a joke a laughably late
primary of 45 days and the money that
would then go into support the 47% that
have consistently voted Republican
doesn't come because we have set up an
incumbent protection plan I am about
ending the incumbent protection plan I
am voting for this I have voted for
August I have voted for June I would
vote for July I would vote for whatever
you put in front of me that wasn't
September um June is the option June is
the way forward in the words of the
Mandalorian this is the way so with that
uh I'm going to call the vote thank you
pass uh representative
qua
yes representative Alexander yes
representative pom Brian yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes repres representative Osborne
yes representative Harvey Bia yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative HR no
representative Hamet no representative
Palmer no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
girl no representative Howard no
Representative rter no chairman Barry
chair CH that the motion about to pass
fails representative Lanes recognized
for another
motion
I
it just to pass yeah it's odd to pass
I'm sorry
I I'm trying to proof read and do this
at the same time and I'm not either very
well just voted I assume you'd want to
vote you like to move on I legislate
representative Brennan I'm happy to move
represent inexpedient to legislator is
there a second uh representative Grill
seconds uh um is there any discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
hearing we just had our discussion the
clerk will call the role on the motion
of inexpedient to
legislate Representative quae no
representative Alexander no
representative Poma Brian no
Representative inberg no representative
Burnham no representative wary no
representative wood no representative
Osbourne No representative Harvey bia no
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Hammer yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes
chairman Barry chair votes no with that
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
fails on a vote of 10 to 10 uh SP 380
will be reported out without
recommendation um I will take the the uh
OTP motion uh representative Lan would
you like representative Brennan to
handle the itl I think that's only fair
um okay with that we will close uh the
executive session on Senate Bill
380 um and we will open up the executive
session on
c22 representative qua is recognized for
a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move that
cacr 22 be found inexpedient to
legislate is there a second
representative Lane seconds is there any
discussion on cacr 22 seeing none the
clerk will call the
role representative
quy yes representative Alexander yes
representative Poma Brian yes
representative inberg yes representative
Burnham yes representative wary yes
representative wood yes yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Palmer yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the the CAC cacr 22 will be
reported out as an legislate I will not
be placing it on the consent calendar we
will see this on the
floor um with that I'll close the
executive session on cacr 22 uh and now
did we get rid of yeah we did like every
Senate bill um so proud of us um we will
open up the executive session on House
Bill 1596 FN requiring a disclosure of
deceptive artificial intelligent usage
and political advertising um
representative Brennan you recognized
for a motion thank you Mr chair I'd like
to move ought to pass is there a second
is there dis uh are there any
amendments yes Mr chair I have an
amendment number 20 24 1209 H I'd like
to move all to pass as
amended okay um representative Brennan
moves Amendment
2024-25 H um it has been seconded by
representative W Oh I thought re second
it did he not did I okay sorry I thought
I heard your I thought I heard your
voice there I didn't to be fair I didn't
look up I just heard the voice and moved
on
um uh representative Bren would you like
to speak to the amendment we are on
discussion of the amendment yes thank
you Mr chair this amendment comes
following a meeting among the minds um
leaders in the Republican party as long
as as well as myself and a few others um
that tried to meld multiple AI bills
that are seen in a few different
committees making sure that definitions
match um and that there would be
cohesion among them this amendment is a
result of that meeting um which was
attended by Speaker Packard chairman
Barry uh Deputy speaker Smith and
chairman of Judiciary uh Representative
Bob Lynn um as well as
others this amendment incorporates all
of the changes suggested during that
meeting um and we had reached consensus
on both this bill as well as the others
and I believe that the bill in judiciary
that this was trying to match up with
has already been passed through
Judiciary and is on the consent calendar
for Thursday's house session this bill
is important to pass and this amendment
is important to pass because it can be
um effective this year and none of the
other AI bills can be effective this
year
further discussion on the amendment
representative rter your mic's on you
okay amend will save you from a hot mic
moment um when you have a mouth like
mine it's you want that protection trust
me um not saying you do I'm just saying
I do um all right any further discussion
on the amendment um I will be voting for
the amendment um we've had a very I
believe longstanding not long standing
but at least newly standing um agreement
that we um let amendments through um
even if we don't necessarily agree with
the underlying bill and I will be
honoring that um so I will be voting for
the amendment um with that U Madam clerk
you want to call the role on
Amendment um
2024-25 to House Bill 1596 FN
representative qua yes representative
Alexander yes representative Poma Brian
yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
hamler yes representative Palmer yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Gill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chairman Barry chair votes
yes with that Amendment 202
24-29 H um passes on a vote of 20 to Zer
representative Brennan is recognized for
a new motion Mr chair like to move ought
to pass as amended please representative
Brennan moves House Bill 1596 FNB ought
to pass as amended with Amendment 202
24-29 representative Ward seconds the
motion as their discussion on the bill
as amended and the ought to pass
motion hearing none the clerk will call
the role Representative
quae no representative Alexander no no
representative pom O Brien no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne no representative
Harvey bia no representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes representative
Hammer yes representative Hamlet yes
representative uh Palmer yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
RoR yes chairman Barry and chair votes
no um with that the motion of op to
passes Amendment fails on a vote of 10
to 10 representative anenberg moves
House Bill 1596 being expedient to
legislate is there a second
representative wor seconds is there
discussion on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 1596 hearing
oh representative inberg you wish you to
speak okay yes thank you Mr chairman um
so in this is an example I believe of uh
putting the cart before the horse um
we're we're not really sure of
the um really uh clear examples of what
we might see in this election cycle
regarding Ai and its potential use
um there was an example um in Pakistan
in their uh most recent uh prime
minister elections um where Imran Khan
was a candidate for election um the the
government had imprisoned him um whether
or not those charges are legitimate or
not I that's not what we're here to talk
about but his campaign was able to use
AI in a way that this bill would
um uh would criminalize um that speech
because or force him to or would have
put him in a situation where he would
have had to declare that that was um
satire or something like that um where
the campaign he did not have the ability
to campaign um in public and his
campaign was able to use AI to create um
electronically generated or artificially
generated voice um campaign uh
information um to gen or to get out to
the public um so that he was able to
effectively run a campaign so that's
just one example um that I have seen of
a of a use of AI that this bill would
criminalize um or prohibit um that could
in fact be utilized in the future and um
on on those grounds uh I would say Free
Speech grounds um I I will oppose that I
I will I will support the itl thank you
further discussion on the most spe legis
repres BR you recognized thank you Mr
chair um this bill does not explicitly
criminalize the use of artificial
intelligence in fact the bill that was
passed in judiciary 20 to nothing on
consent explicitly criminalizes the use
of artificial intelligence this simply
provides an Avenue for complaint an
Avenue for injunction and it is solely
related to 90 days before a candidate
appears on a ballot and has to do
explicitly with deep fakes fraudulent
deep fakes deceptive manipulated deep
fakes it is not if the candidate
themselves is um putting forward
artificial intelligence that they
support um that is simply getting across
their message when they are unable the
purpose of this is not to um
inhibit technological advances this is
simply to protect our
voters our candidates from being
fraudulently
deceptively manipulated by technology to
relay uh to make them to make voters
believe something something happened
that did not actually occur in real
life that's what this bill does so if
you have a problem with explicit
criminalization of artificial
intelligence I would imagine that you
might want to pull that Judiciary bill
off consent and argue against it um that
bill has bipartisan support and the
language from that bill the definitions
from that that bill are now included in
this
bill and this has bipartisan language in
it supported
by and encouraged by and reached
consensus by chairman Lynn and Judiciary
as well as other members who were
present at the meeting of the AI bills
just last
week so I'm particularly
confused why this
committee would be voting against this
bill when this is the only opportunity
we have to put something on the books to
give law enforcement the AG's office the
Secretary of State a tool in their
toolbox to make a change
to to stop the dissemination of
disinformation during this critical
election year and this is not a
Republican or Democrat ratic thing this
is this is a bipartisan thing there's
bipartisan support for this bill so I'm
I'm particularly confused and I would
love an explanation if anyone would care
to provide one to me why suddenly this
is getting
um the treatment it's getting thank you
further discussion on the motion of in
speing to legislate on House Bill
1596 venberg so I think we're in a
position where it's much more likely
that if we're focused on dissemination
of um content that the um social media
companies and platforms have been
looking into updating their terms of
service that would potentially constrain
some of this in some way that would not
be a legal setting or a legal standard
where um you know once you once you
accept those terms of services anybody
that's ended up in Facebook jail or you
know um similar situations will tell you
those could be much more onerous than
having um and probably the way to go at
this point rather than having um
government step in and create an extra
layer of legislation that could
potentially infringe on free speech and
I'd also add that um having somebody
declare um their opinions or um content
as satire or any any other way um I I
don't think that's really I don't think
that's really effective when if they
were going to if this content was going
to be used in a way to affect an
election that would have to be um you
know there' have to be disclaimers and
that would fall under current law um so
I don't think I don't think this bill is
needed I think it's I think it's early
in the process we we don't really know
what situations we might encounter and
therefore trying
to legislate pre- crime I I don't think
that's really effective
thank representative Lane
recognized thank you Mr chair I would
Echo um everything that representative
uh Brennan uh expressed
eloquently um this would not uh affect
free free speech if it's free speech and
it's the person doing it and there are
very certain rules about what the First
Amendment covers it's not unlimited but
particularly in a political situation
our like you said our existing statutes
should handle it um but there are
circumstances where there will be fraud
we've already had some one which would
have been covered by the statute but I
think we need to look forward and
realize that this is something that's
looming and is uh people are sounding
the alarm and this just gives people the
tools to do it and if people don't want
to do it I mean if people want to do it
and test the waters that's on them but I
think we need to make sure that uh we
don't have a lot of deep fakes going
around for this election because it's
going to be contentious and it's going
to be difficult and I'd like to see
something in place frankly to keep both
sides reigned
in further discussion on the motion of
inexp to legislate hearing none uh the
clerk will call the role on the motion
toped to legislate to House Bill 1596 FN
representative quy
yes representative Alexander yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative HR no
representative Hamlet no representative
Palmer no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative Howard no
representative Rapter no uh chairman
Barry chair votes yes without the motion
any speed legislate fails in vote of 10
to 10 House Bill 1596 will be reported
out without recommendation
representative mberg will be responsible
for the motion of spe legislate report
and representative will be responsible
for the ought to pass as amended report
uh with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 1596 we'll take up
our last piece of business which is
House Bill 1091 representative Lane
we well like I said I I haven't gotten
all the way through it um I I just need
I probably need like 20 minutes just to
go through the rest of it and make sure
that all the changes got in I and I
don't know if rep qu's had an
opportunity to go through it yeah I hate
to make everybody wait and then we could
try and do it before lunch
but um yeah so I think here's what we do
um because I'm going to have there
already are a few changes so it's
already going to have to go back cor
correct so that's where that and that's
where I'm getting to my point yeah
is we have to act on this bill today um
I want to get it as close to
right as possible understanding that we
will probably miss something so
understanding that we will probably
catch something in the next week and a
half um in fact I would put money down
that we will catch something in the next
week and a half um let's do this we're
going to have to bring a floor Amendment
anyways I think we're at that
stage um to clean it up and I hate floor
amendments and I know you hate floor
amendments I hate them so much I hate
them so much especially on a 13 page
Bill correct but I think that's I think
that's where we're at because even if we
get even if we get it up to OS and get
it back we're still going to have to
we're still going to find something and
we're still going to bring a floor
Amendment so let's I I think instead of
trying to get the amendment in front of
us perfect my recommendation is we pass
the amendment that's in front of us I
will be voting otpa just for disclosure
and then representative Lane will bring
forward a floor Amendment together I'll
put my name on it and that will
hopefully what little what little good
favor I have with my side of the aisle
um that will help and what favor you
have with your side of the aisle will
help um and I think we'll be able to get
the floor Amendment through um but
that's I think that's where we're at
because otherwise we would probably be
here till 4 o'clock um oh I don't think
so because the changes are no the
changes are small and she said she would
put it to the top of her list okay and
you know I think if if I can just get 20
minutes to do it get it over to her I
mean if we take a lunch break and come
back at 1 we should have it all right is
there any I know there are some members
that have ha ask I just hate to ask
people to vote for something that you
know are changes and that it's not what
um we all want and I just don't think
that's a good way to do something
especially when the subcommittee works
so hard on this so okay that's is there
I I know there members that have to
leave so who has to
leave
anyone does anyone else need to leave
it's okay if you do it's not the end of
the world um I'm just trying to figure
it out okay so I think we'll do that um
represent Lane so you'll have an
amendment for us ready to go at let's
say you have to leave at 130 represent
girl so let's reconvene at 1:5 give us
the longest run on that as possible um
and we'll get it done um okay uh yes
representative qule you want to turn
turn on your microphone just we're still
yes if representative Lanes uh does not
get her changes back from OS by that
time yeah I think we should just go
ahead and follow your your thought of
passing this amendment and then fixing
it with the floor amendment is
distasteful as that might be yes I'm not
a huge I I share the animosity towards a
floor amend so I'm just trying to be
respectful of the memb time um I think
that would be just an alternative in
case her is that is that okay okay with
you representative
Lane I know it's not ideal but we're in
an unideal situation and we're trying to
make the best of it it it it sounds as
though the uh the items she's finding
and I'll spend the next hour or so
looking through it too okay but uh
sounds like the thing she's talking
about changing are pretty minor and
could be easily explained on the floor
okay so let's come back at 1:00
hopefully we're done by then um we're
going to vote by5 so um I'm not saying
we will vote we might vote earlier than
that but if we get to 115 and we we're
not ready we're going to we're going to
vote
regardless and move on and go about our
business is that okay with everyone
seeing nods repres part the mie you okay
with that okay all right I'll see you
o'clock
e
for
okay uh we'll come back representative
Lane where are we with an
amendment I don't have it yet okay I
mean I dropped it off in person she
started working on it at noon has to be
reviewed by two people there were only
four changes I think but it has to be
reviewed by two attorneys and it was
lunchtime so we're I'm waiting with
faded breath so what do we want to do I
want to give her a few I can go over
there and then call you if you want or I
can try and call her I don't know I
don't know that I have her number though
um
okay I'll give her another five minutes
how about
that yeah I said I wanted to be done
with the vote or start the vote by 115
so yeah that's
right okay we'll stay in The Recess for
minutes
e
okay uh we're going to have we're going
to come back we're waiting for them to
print it we have it right it's done
right so yeah so they're printing it um
so before we make a 91a violation we
were discussing the amendment I said
it's time to bring we need to have those
discussions in public so um there
concern well C you want to speak to your
concern you want to speak to your
concern about election cycle page 20
line
27 sure yeah
sure yes on page four of the amendment
as it presently stands on uh where is it
27 uh item Roman numeral 23 election
cycle means the period of time beginning
on the eth day after a state general
election through 21 days after the next
state general election that implies an
overlap between two successive election
Cycles now I I think that could work but
I'm not sure if that's was
the okay that wasn't the intent I think
when we talked about it so
um so I I missed that it didn't get
changed we'll we'll fix that in a flam
start calling it The flam it's way more
it's way more appealing than Flor M flam
it could be fancy but like FL and the
other thing that was brought to our
attention is that with the date changed
to the election cycle that starts on
November 26
2024 the effective date of the bill
cannot be January 1 2025 so we're going
to probably change that in the what did
you call it the FL the FL I'm being
flam we can set it on fire yeah maybe we
should go with flam then um we could get
the bay really excited okay so November
26 2024 to TI to that date okay so have
to fix that you can't have it can't go
backwards all right where are we with
the printing do we know it's a Christina
went to to print it
okay um well tell you what we can do
some procedural stuff and at least bang
that out of the way um so we were on a
motion of op to pass as amended on the
amendment to adop the am yeah well I'm
going we're not going to adopt this
amendment because we're going to adopt
the the new Amendment so um can we
withdraw the amend yeah so instead of
voting it down I'd ask representative
Lane to withdraw her
motion uh to move Amendment 202
24-13
h i so withdraw 20 and I will withdraw
my second 1193 yep so at least we'll get
that out of the way and then um just so
you guys know I I do we are going to be
out of here by 1:30 so when this
amendment comes we're going to vote and
I'm sure there will be changes with a
flam or a flam yeah um with caramel
sauce um actually you know while we're
here this uh they can take care of this
um this might be the last time we meet
as a full committee um I don't know
unless this I don't know if there's any
more Senate bills coming there's no more
bills in our possession at a minimum um
so um I want to say thank you guys it's
been if I don't see you again I hope I
see you again if I don't see you in the
full committee I do have a gift for our
clerk um which is why I had the
Starbucks today um so I want to say
thank you so much Madam clerk uh it's a
year salary so don't spend it all in one
place um but her notes are excellent and
it's a uh it's a horrible horrible
horrible job and thank God she did it um
but I wanted to say thank you and thank
you from the committee um for doing
those uh that hard the hard work so um
we'll get that out of the way and then
uh that's why I had Starbucks today so
when they when they uh when they take a
picture of me they're like he's not a
man of the people he's got the Starbucks
it was for you it was fre I I was hoping
that i' converted you to the dark side
but you have not uh they they they did
not know what to do with me when I said
this morning uh yeah I want a black
coffee medium and they went what size is
it
medium I don't know what size they have
at
starbu so um but yes any thank you so
much representative Grill um all right I
guess we'll stand and recess for like
two minutes and we come
[Music]
back
e
okay we're going to come back I assume
it's been two minutes um representative
Lane you recognized for a motion
um I I move um that Amendment
2024-25
uh be adopted and I'll second the motion
um we're now on discussion on amendment
2024-25 is there any discussion on the
amendment um I can do you want me to try
and highlight the big change was the
date yeah was was the date um in in in
the online uh system there were a few
Nets um that there was a numbering issue
that she picked up and um I can't there
were four I can't remember the other one
but oh adding a period in on something
so big changes those were big changes
but the important one was the date and
um then I've got you know comments from
other ones that we uh we can do either
by a floor Amendment or wait till it
goes over to the Senate so we'll try for
a floor Amendment give them less excuse
to Tinker with it okay um okay any
further discussion on Amendment 2024-25
H hearing none clerk will call the RO
representative qua yes uh representative
Alexander representative pom Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey Bia yes
representative Wayne yes representative
Ward yes representative HR yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes uh
chairman Barry chair votes yes with that
Amendment 2024-25 carries on a vote of
20 to Zer representative Lane is
motion I moved um HB uh 1091 uh ought to
pass as amended representative Lane
moves House Bill 109 91 as amended by
Amendment 2024-25 H has ought to pass as
amended I second the motion is there
discussion on the bill as
amended hearing none the clerk will call
the role representative qua yes
representative Alexander yes
representative pom O Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative bernham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative Harvey buia yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative HR yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Palmer yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter yes and
chairman Barry uh the chair votes yes uh
so with that uh House Bill 1091 passes
is ought to pass as amended um on a vote
of 20 to0 it's not going to go on the
consent calendar because we're probably
going to need a floor Amendment so why
why put it on the why do that and then
have to get 10 signatures when we're
going to have to amend it anyways um so
with that that concludes our business I
hope to see you guys maybe we'll meet
one more time I hope so um maybe you
don't I don't know um but uh if I don't
you
e